If you believe that Russia's invasion of Ukraine
is going to be the only one of the decade,
you may be right... But... in
order to make such a forecast
with confidence would require us to know
for sure how China is going to behave.
You already know that this country has
been threatening to invade Taiwan for
some time now. And, I’m sure many of
you would think that sooner or later
the island will likely become the next
Ukraine, but... What if we told you that
there are those who think that ultimately the
Asian Ukraine could be Vietnam and not Taiwan?
And, keep in mind, we are not
talking about mere speculation.
There are plenty of arguments
to believe that the risk exists.
Tension rises between China, Vietnam and
the Philippines over disputed islands
In fact, China has even sunk Vietnamese
fishing boats in the South China Sea. But,
let's be honest, this is nothing new for Vietnam,
after all, the two countries were already at war
in 1979, just after the end of the famous civil
war in which the United States intervened.
[But, wait a minute, aren't they both supposed
to be countries with communist regimes?
Didn't international socialism unite them?)
Yes, both were – and supposedly still
are – staunch communist regimes, but,
when it comes to power struggles...
ideology takes a back seat.
The fact is that it should come as no surprise
that Vietnam is trying to strengthen itself as
much as possible to avoid another possible
Chinese invasion. And what can I say,
history tells us that this is the smartest
move it can make. And, not surprisingly,
this is something that, as we will see,
is of great interest to the United States.
Think about it, the United States wants to curb
Chinese expansionism in the South China Sea,
an objective shared by Vietnam, a country that
could play a crucial role in that project.
With almost 100 million inhabitants and impressive
economic growth in recent years – Vietnam is
gradually emerging as another future regional
counterweight to China. One more. You know,
alongside Japan, South Korea, Singapore, the
Philippines, possibly India and so many other
countries in the area. China's position is not
as strong as it might appear at first glance.
However, we must not forget that Vietnam
is still a communist dictatorship,
and making alliances with authoritarian
regimes can lead to a lot of problems.
Just look at the NATO situation with Turkey...
But we'll talk about that in another video.
For now, the question is: can the
West really trust Vietnam? To what
extent could it become a reliable
military partner for the United
States? Could tensions between Vietnam
and China end up provoking another war?
Today we are going to answer these questions,
but first let's look at a bit of history.
(THE CROSSROADS OF ASIAN COMMUNISM)
When we look at history and how China
and Vietnam are organized internally,
we see that, at first glance, they
basically appear to be parallel realities:
Both countries carried out socialist revolutions,
both established communist dictatorships
that are still in place, and both began
to reform their economies in order to
open up to the international market.
Vietnam started its economic
reform in 1986 with Doi Moi,
that is 8 years after Deng Xiaoping's
economic reforms were launched in China.
The fact is that both countries began to promote
private ownership of agricultural property and,
in general, in the rest of the economy.
They also boosted foreign investment and
intensified their trade relations with the world.
Thanks to these changes, they
eventually reaped a juicy result:
as you can see, their economies began to take off.
As you can see, China, which began
its reforms almost a decade earlier,
distanced itself from Vietnam, especially when
it joined the World Trade Organization at the
beginning of the 21st century. Nevertheless,
overall, the two countries have followed a
more than remarkable trajectory. In just 30
years, Vietnam has multiplied the real value
of its production by 12 times, while China
has increased its own by almost 20 times.
And the truth is that we are talking about two
countries with many similarities... But that,
at the same time, are also very different.
In the case of Vietnam, in addition to arriving
almost a decade late to the wave of economic
reforms, it must be taken into account that
when it did finally arrive, this country had
just gone through two wars: a civil war in
which the United States participated and,
later, a war against China, which showed
up in defense of the Cambodian regime that
committed one of the most extensive
acts of genocide in history, Pol Pot.
In general, we can say that Vietnam embraced
reforms when it was poorer and had even more
problems of all kinds than China. In part,
that difference explains the current gap.
Of course, today, the differences
go beyond the purely economic realm.
(China, between collective power
and the personalism of Xi Jinping. – ABC)
Exactly, while in recent years personalism
taken to the extreme has regained
strength with Xi Jinping in China,
in Vietnam things look different, and
proof of this is news stories like this:
(Vietnam President Nguyen Xuan Phuc quits amid
Communist Party corruption crackdown. – CNN)
You see, in China, since 1989, the general
secretary of the Communist Party has also
been the president of the country. In Vietnam,
on the other hand, this seems unthinkable today.
In fact, the Vietnamese communist
dictatorship rests on four pillars:
the General Secretariat, the Prime Minister,
the President and the Leader of the National
Assembly. Since Ho Chi Minh's death in
1969, each of these positions has been
held by different people who function, in
a way, as counterweights to each other.
In fact, the National Assembly of Vietnam,
which is obviously not democratic,
at least has some real activity. It can
even veto resolutions and, if necessary,
propose motions of confidence against the
prime minister. So far this has allowed the
official apparatus to be somewhat more oxygenated.
Meanwhile, in China there was the alternation of
the leader and the political elites... But
with Xi Jinping, all that has disappeared.
So what does all this mean? Basically, no
one in Vietnam can change course rapidly,
as Xi Jinping can in China. And it also generally
means fewer restrictions for the population.
For example, while in China Facebook and YouTube
are totally blocked, in Vietnam there is free
access, albeit with some restrictions, even
to videos that criticize the Communist Party.
But apart from the domestic political project,
the area where we find the biggest differences
between the two countries is mainly in their
policy in the South China Sea, although, well,
they also have one important thing in common
there: both countries claim the same territories.
And that means that tensions could flare
up and history could repeat itself again.
Don't forget that both countries
were at war as recently as 1979.
The question is: How does Vietnam hope to
prevent tension from flaring
up with its northern neighbor?
Well, let's take a look.
(FROM RUSSIA, WITH LOVE)
It is inevitable, every time we hear about
Vietnam, we immediately think of that war
about which dozens of movies have been
made and in which the United States was
involved in supporting the south of the
country with tens and tens of thousands
of soldiers. To give you an idea, in 1968
the North American power had almost 600,000
soldiers deployed in this country. In
total, the United States participated
in this war for 12 very long years.
But I'm sure what many of you didn't
know is that right after this war
ended, China invaded Vietnam in 1979.
And apparently today things
would not be much different:
Vietnam's exposure to China remains enormous.
Look at this map: If you pay attention,
geographically Vietnam is totally at the
mercy of China, either by its border in
the north – which was where the Chinese
invaded them in '79 – or by the coast where,
in addition to being practically surrounded,
they would face the largest navy by
number of ships in the whole world.
And let's not forget that to the southwest
there is Cambodia, an ally of China,
and then there is Laos, which could change
sides at the convenience of the highest bidder.
Not surprisingly, faced with such a scenario,
the question is, can Vietnam really
have a clearly independent discourse?
This is basically the reason why Vietnam
has been moving closer and closer to
countries such as Japan and India in recent
years, both militarily and commercially,
But, let's be honest, the friendship between
these countries is rather superficial. If
we really want to identify the one who
has always been Vietnam's best friend,
we have to go to the country that has been in all
the headlines around the world this past year.
Exactly, we are talking about Russia.
Since the Ho Chi Minh era, Moscow's influence
in the country has already been infinitely
greater than that of Beijing. In a way,
this has much to do with the fact that
the roots of Vietnam's communist thinking
come directly from Soviet Marxism-Leninism.
It is not surprising, therefore, that its ties
with the Soviet Union were so close. Which
explains, to a large extent, why the United
States took the Vietnam War so seriously. A
conflict in which North Vietnamese troops were
supported and assisted by the Soviet Union.
Which is exactly what happened again when China
invaded the country in 1979 in retaliation for
Vietnam attacking and overthrowing the
bloody Khmer Rouge regime in Cambodia.
Whether the invasion was coming from the
Americans or the Chinese, the Soviet Union,
the most loyal partner of communist Vietnam,
helped the country by sending a lot of weapons
such as anti-aircraft missiles, light machine
guns and the infamous AK-47 assault rifle.
The point is that if their
relations were already close,
from that era on the friendship grew much
stronger. In fact, today Russia remains the
largest arms partner of the Vietnamese army.
Russia even has preferential access to one
of the most important Vietnamese
bases, the one in Cam Ranh Bay.
But pay attention, because
that's not the end of it.
Vietnam did not rely on the Soviet
Union and today's Russia just to get
weapons. Economic cooperation has
also been key during this time.
Do you want an example? Well,
in recent years Vietnam has tried to
extract oil in the South China Sea,
with the help of a lot of multinationals. For
example, with the Spanish company, Repsol.
However, we are talking about extraction from
disputed territories, and, naturally, the oil was
going to come out faster and with fewer problems
if some Russian state-owned company got involved
and managed to intimidate China a little bit, just
a little bit. [Particularly for fear of damaging
its relations with Moscow. Or rather, Xi Jinping's
determination to maintain those relations].
And, of course, the first to jump on this
opportunity was Rosneft, although it later
sold its entire stake to Zarubezhneft,
another Russian state-owned energy company.
So let me ask you a question, how do you
think Vietnam repays Russia's favors? Well,
news stories like this are
a pretty good indication:
(Vietnam and Thailand abstain from UN vote
to condemn Russia's Ukraine annexation. RFA)
Exactly. Vietnam is one of the few countries in
the world that avoids condemning
the Russian invasion of Ukraine.
And, it makes sense, if it weren't for the
constant support of the Soviet Union in the
past and the current Russia today, Vietnam
would possibly not be what it is today.
But of course, if China were to take the
initiative and punish or change the Vietnamese
government, or even invade the country and turn
it into a satellite State, the Russians would
be of no help. Today, given the new capabilities
of the Chinese army and the manifest weaknesses
of Russia, it would be very difficult, if not
impossible, for Moscow to be of any help to them.
And make no mistake about it. This is crystal
clear to the decision makers in Hanoi:
they have one of the world's major powers on
their doorstep, a power that is increasingly
expansionist and with which they do
not get along particularly well. And,
in any case, they do not want
to be a satellite country.
To avoid a possible clash, in recent years,
Hanoi has been trying to improve its relations
with Beijing. This is not just a territorial
or military issue. To put it in perspective,
almost 40% of all Vietnamese imports come from
China, including integrated circuits, telephones,
semiconductors... In short, practically everything
the country needs to develop technologically.
This explains, for example, why both
countries have carried out dozens of
military cooperation exercises
during the current century.
And above all, it explains the foreign
policy based on the philosophy of the 3 noes:
Not to allow foreign military bases in Vietnam,
not to be part of military alliances, and not
to support one country in its fight against
another. All this in order not to anger China.
But what if this strategy
was a mistake? Nevertheless,
tensions in the South China Sea with
China have been rising over the past
decade and the situation in the region is
no longer to be taken lightly. Watch this
space:(LEAVING THE PAST BEHIND)
We've told you before how Vietnam embarked
on a series of pro-market economic reforms
starting in '86. It's something we talked about
in detail in a past video here on VisualPolitik.
But for those of you who haven't
seen it or simply don't remember it:
At the beginning, these reforms were
limited to the agricultural sector,
and later jumped to the rest of the economic
sectors. One of the most important was the
pursuit of the country's industrialization
at all costs. In order to succeed,
this required receiving and courting
investors from the rest of the world.
And, trust me, they took it very seriously.
Nowadays it is not uncommon to see brands
from all over the world producing in Vietnam. We
are talking about companies like Samsung, H&M,
Adidas, Nike and Foxconn. In fact, Vietnam's
largest customer by far is the United States.
This is not surprising. Relations with
the North American superpower have
improved greatly in recent years.
Gone are the times of war and mistrust. In 1995
the two countries formally restored diplomatic
relations, in 2000 they signed a Bilateral Trade
Agreement, in 2007 Vietnam joined the World Trade
Organization with Washington's explicit support,
and in 2016 the United States completely lifted
the arms embargo on Vietnam, allowing for greater
cooperation on security and defense issues.
We could even see images like these:
Since then, the two countries have conducted
numerous joint military exercises and routinely
collaborate on maritime security and freedom
of navigation in the Indo-Pacific region.
Now, while we have told you that
Vietnam has tried to get along
as well as possible with China, what
explains its sudden desire to create
a link with its historical archenemy
and China's current great adversary?
Well, beyond economic issues, the truth is that in
Hanoi they do not trust Beijing at all. In fact,
in 2014, tension between the two countries
reached an extreme level when China brought
a semi-submersible oil platform to explore and
exploit oil within Vietnamese maritime territory.
And not only that, the construction of
artificial islands around the Spratly and
Paracel archipelagos, which Vietnam claims as its
own, has caused tension to grow in the region,
especially because of the military hardware
that China is installing on these islands.
That is why in Hanoi they now seem
to understand that neither Moscow
nor Beijing are their safest bets,
but that instead they need to look
to the United States and its orbit
of allied countries in the area.
Of course, Washington has seen this shift
as a stroke of good fortune: as another
potential partner to add to its already long
list of countries angry or suspicious of China.
And in a way that's what
explains news items like these:
(29 March 2018: The United States Transfers Six
Metal Shark Patrol Boats to Vietnam. US Embassy in
Vietnam)(20 November 2019: US gifts
ship to Vietnam to boost patrols in
disputed South China Sea. – SCMP)
(17 December 2022: Analysis:
Vietnam shifts gears on arms trade as
it loosens ties with Russia. – Reuters)
Now, instead of buying Russian weapons,
it is American, South Korean and Israeli
weapons that are flooding into Vietnam.
Now, does this mean that Vietnam
is going to change its "3 noes"
philosophy and throw itself completely into
the arms of Uncle Sam? Well, definitely not.
Vietnam is a strange case
of a country that right now
seems to want to get along with Beijing,
Moscow and Washington at the same time.
And make no mistake: Vietnam is still a communist
dictatorship. Western political and democratic
values are not part of the Communist Party,
and this limits the confidence that the United
States places in Vietnam. Not surprisingly, it
is practically impossible to imagine Vietnam
intervening alongside the United States
in Taiwan to prevent an attack by China.
But now the question is for you, if you
were Vietnam, who would you side with:
Moscow, Beijing or Washington? Leave
us your answers in the comments and
let's open a debate. If you
found this video interesting,
don't forget to like and subscribe to
VisualPolitik if you haven't already done so.
Thank you very much for watching,
All the best and see you next time.